this video is sponsored by Squarespace
this year's fall season is in tip-top
shape offering not only exciting new
series but also a lot of sequels for
popular anime personally I consider fall
or summer to be some sort of blockbuster
season kind of like what summers are for
Hollywood not to take away from other
seasons but the four seasons given us
some great anime recently so without any
further ado let's look at the top 10
most anticipated anime from the upcoming
fall 2019 season we start off the list
with a kabuki Joe Sherlock now on the
list an anime original this time we look
at what seems to be Sherlock Holmes
meets Shinjuku's red-light district
overall Kabul Keiko Sherlock looks like
another detective in a section of Tokyo
anime it seems to be a mystery show with
comedy also I won't blame you if it
gives you some durarara vibe production
i.g usually does well in shows with this
ambiance such as Psychopaths there's
more on that later
I think the hype is understandable plus
the character and background designs are
really quite stylish well who's up for
more comedic mysteries you know I'm down
for it
[Music]
at number nine we have be stars I didn't
know that Zootopia had an anime joking
aside be stars is a slice-of-life anime
in a world of anthropomorphic animals
the main character the adolescent wolf
mageot she in a pickle being a wolf
makes it hard to fit in with his peers
even though he has a gentle heart and
his part of his school's drama club the
fact remains that he's a carnival who's
a prime suspect for a murder that he
didn't commit
through his steady interactions with the
rest of the animals he starts opening up
and seeing what the world around him is
truly like why it's too early to tell I
think it does show promise I mean this
man has been topping some polls in Japan
and it's unmistakably a sleeper hit
let's check out the story and find out
why a there's none other than our hero
no Sora I think it's about time that we
got a new basketball anime this one
tells the story of Sora a young upstart
who carries his mom's wishes to dominate
the basketball world he joins a club
only to find out it's a hangout for
delinquents a toxic environment like
that is a no-no for anyone with
aspirations with things as they are it's
up to Sora's determination and love for
the sport to rekindle the club's passion
for basketball now overall I think this
manga is underrated it's more realistic
than what we've gotten used to in
basketball series and I think that the
well-grounded dramas a selling point for
those who appreciate that sort of thing
despite not being as flashy as it Sports
anime brethren it translates well into
an anime format so I encourage you to
give it a chance and check it out for a
unique basketball anime experience
he's sunny busca the anime a fait Grand
order finds its way to the seventh spot
on the list and here we start with the
established IPS with a franchise as big
as fait grand order it was only a matter
of time before an anime project got
announced and here we are getting it
this upcoming season in a strange twist
for a lot of non players this anime
adaptation would cover the Babylonia arc
in the game for those of you who don't
know it's the seventh arc in the first
part of the fake Grand order game expect
fan favorites to take the spotlight in
this series along with the ever-popular
Gilgamesh this fake Grand order anime is
quite the star studded adaptation the
good thing with these fgo arcs names
signal era T's is that you don't need to
watch everything in order sure you'd
miss out some things here and there but
nothing really that major it's obvious
that this is an anime made for the
players of the massively popular game
but hey it's never too late to get into
the game or to get up to speed with the
show in the end I think that the
Babylonia Ark still stands alone well
enough as a solo up at number 6 we have
the second half of sword art online
Alice's ation after months of waiting we
finally make the much awaited return to
the underworld and reunite with Kyoto
who's been reduced to merely a husk of
the legendary hero that he once was
after the events of the first half he
couldn't have picked a worse time as
well the ancient evil vector returns and
mobilizes the forces of the dark
territory in a raid that aims to
eradicate the human Empire once and for
all
standing in his way other now fragmented
forces of humanity led by what remains
in the order of the integrity Knights
are sooner Leifer sinon and the rest of
the gang into the fray clinging on to
the hope of Kyoto's return it's up to
the girls to turn the tides of the war
that will decide the fate of virtual
reality SAO fans rejoice you're in for
an awesome ride this coming season as
Alice's Asian looks to wrap up in
spectacular fashion
30 extra food Wars returns for its
fourth season and it finds its way to
number 5 on our list food Wars has
always enthralled me with its creativity
Sigmund
flair and a knack for offering the best
of cooking techniques and fanservice the
anime has come a long way and fans just
can't wait to see more of soma Erina and
the newly formed rebels girl group
taking them on is the elite 10th Council
led by none other than airinas father
this season we'll wrap up the central
art that began in the third season after
where it left off it's time for the rest
of the regimented cuisine matches
prepare yourselves for more exciting
cooking showdowns with the academies and
arenas future on the line defeat isn't
an option this is truly a fourth season
to look out for the seven deadly sins
wrath of the Gods is fourth on our list
the seven deadly sins getting a
deserving third season actually
surprised me it's not that a second
sequel to one of the rising stars in the
world of shonan's happening it's that
the change to Studio Deen that surprised
me a bit but given their track record I
think that ties in good hands expect
this season to adapt another hundred
chapters or so this means that we'll
probably see the end of the new holy war
arc setting a fitting conclusion to the
anime story should there be a need to in
that case we'll likely see the fated
showdown between the seven deadly sins
and celtris as well as the decisive
battle against the demon king a grand
finale for the ages and that's why the
seven deadly sins third season is high
on this list
everyone's anticipating one hell of a
finish
third on the list is psycho-pass three
what a pleasant surprise this was many
thought a psychopath wouldn't be getting
a third season before the bomb was
dropped four months ago yes the hit
series that shook up the early 2010's
and raised questions on morals and
justice it's continuing after a
stunningly spectacular first season many
fans felt let down with the second
season that's nothing that this season
can't turn around though it spearheaded
by production i.g Psychopaths looks to
regain its former glory as the premiere
psychological thriller that tackled
psychological and societal issues I'm
sure that people will have high hopes
for this season so what are you waiting
for start your life-changing trip into
the world of Psychopaths now by the time
the third season rolls around this
October but guarantee you won't regret a
thing at number two we have a somewhat
familiar title in the layed of the
immortal stuck in the midst of sequels
comes this new anime series
well not exactly if you think that the
title blade of the immortal sounds
familiar that's because this upcoming
series is essentially a reboot of the
2008 anime for those unfamiliar with the
source material blade of the immortal
tells the story of asana Rin and her
bodyguard mangie mangie is the titular
character being cursed with immortality
his goal kill a thousand evil men in
order to rid himself of the curse
overall it's one of those dark action
titles that features more mature sides
of the genre let's hope this 2019
version will make the strength of the
series shine through trust me there's a
lot to like about the manga thanks to
its stylish action sequences as well as
its themes of immortality and redemption
now the new versions main selling point
seems to be the fact that it's gonna be
a full adaptation of the manga that's
not something you see every day is it
with a lot of manga adaptations
ultimately ending up having filler arcs
or ending blade of the immortal seems to
be one of the promising action series in
this coming season whether you're
originally a fan of the manga or not
our number-one most anticipated anime
this fall is the 4th season of my hero
academia further solidifying its status
as one of the great shown in series of
the newer generation my hero academia is
slated to get its fourth season in a few
months time ever since the first season
Daegu and the rest of you a high have
captivated fans with a slew of
adventures iconic show doubts and drama
this time our heroes prepare for a new
chapter in their lives
school's out an internship awaits what
awaits them is the new villain called
overhaul with all might effectively out
of commission a group of heroes take on
what seems to be their biggest challenge
yet
how far will their lessons take them as
they face this newest threat with many
positive reviews coming from those
who've already seen the advanced
screenings my hero academia is looking
to come up with yet another plus ultra
showing knowing the series track record
nothing less is to be expected from the
next big thing in the world of Shonen
fool that wraps up this edition of our
top ten list which one among these shows
are you most excited to see before in
this video I'd like to give a shout out
to this video sponsor Squarespace
Squarespace is one of the easiest to use
and beautiful website development tools
out there with 24/7 365 days support you
can find everything in one platform
there's no need to add additional
plugins no updates and no patches ever
I'm still working on my website at the
moment and I really like the fact that
all images hosted on Squarespace can be
edited directly within your browser
using Squarespace is built in image
editor crop resize rotate adjust
brightness and contrast and much more
it's all in there Squarespace is
offering my viewers 10% off their first
purchase just go to squarespace.com
slash Vinnie tube that's VI n III t ub e
or just click the link in the
description to sign up and start
building your online presence today
that's it and I hope to see you again
soon
[Music]